Levi: Hi, everyone.
My name is Alon Levi.
I'm a software engineer
on the Google App Engine team
and this talk is called
"From Spark Plug to Drive Train:
Life of an App Engine Request."
Throughout the course
of this talk,
you can go and use
Google Moderator,
which is an application
built on App Engine,
to submit and vote
on questions,
which I'll then answer
at the end.
If you're interested,
go to
code.google.
com/events/io/questions,
click on the App Engine track
in the middle,
and then the title
of this talk
should be
on the left-hand side.
Yeah.
So this talk is called,
"From spark plug
to drive train,"
and what I want
to do is take a look
under the hood of App Engine
with you guys
and see how App Engine works.
See how the App Engine
infrastructure works.
This is not a talk about how to
build App Engine applications.
There are a number
of other talks
throughout the course
of the conference
that are gonna cover that.
But as a software engineer,
I find that
when I understand how things
work under the hood,
it makes me a little more
confident
and a little more comfortable
working with the system,
so with that,
I want to get started.
So the first thing
I want to talk about
is designing for scale
and reliability.
Not necessarily
App Engine centric.
We're just talking about what
makes a web app--
a web app stack scale.
And we'll take a look
at the LAMP stack
and look at some of the
principles there,
although they apply to other
web infrastructure as well.
Then I want to take
a look and talk about
some of the lessons learned
from sort of
the progression
of that LAMP stack
and see the lessons
that we applied
while building App Engine.
And then we'll take
a look at some of the--
some different kinds
of requests and how--
as they pass through
App Engine infrastructure
and how that affects the way
you design your application
and the way your application
actually runs.
Then I'm gonna go back over
the design motivations
and take a look
at that in more detail.
And then I'm gonna
go over some numbers
regarding App Engine.
So, first off, let's talk
about web stacks.
So this is a very
high-level overview
of the Google App Engine stack.
It's really exciting because
this is something
we haven't shared
publicly before.
You can kind of see
that it's a standard,
three-tiered web topology.
You've got your front-ends
or routing on the left side.
Your application layer
down the middle.
And on the right side,
we've got our persistence layer
and other APIs.
To draw to something similar
that you guys may have seen,
this is a slide from
a talk Brad Fitzpatrick gave
about LiveJournal in 2007.
Talking about how they--
their progression
through the LAMP stack
and how they
made it work for them.
So as you can see,
it's sort of similar
to what we have going on
with App Engine.
You've got their Perlbal
reverse proxies,
which are their front-ends
in blue,
application servers
application layer in green,
and then APIs
and persistence in red.
So before we talk more
about App Engine,
I want to take a step back--
or way back--
and talk about web
infrastructure in general
starting with the very
basic LAMP stack.
So as many of you know,
LAMP stack
is Linux, Apache, MySQL,
and originally Perl,
but it could be any
programming language.
In this, the very basic
LAMP stack,
you've got one machine running
an Apache web server
with Perl and a MySQL
database
all in one machine.
So when a request comes
in from the network,
it hits this one box,
Apache serves the web request,
turns up Perl instance,
which may or may not
make calls to MySQL
and returns the response.
This is a great start
and a nice way
to start building
web applications,
but it's not very scalable.
You have a shared machine
for your database
and your web server
and very soon
you'll realize
that your databases
consume the resources
which your web server
could be using
to serve live traffic.
Additionally,
this is one single machine.
If you have to do any upgrades
or if there are any failures,
you're basically out of luck.
The next step is
to take your database
and move it onto
a different machine.
This frees up some resources
for your web server.
Pretty much the same.
It requires a little bit
of management
and configuration for MySQL,
but not too much.
It's fairly straightforward.
And it gives you--
It frees up part
of your web server
to serve more traffic.
So this is sort of
the next progressive step
in building your applica--
in your web stack.
So this scales
up to the amount
that your one Apache server
can handle in web traffic.
But you've now got two single
points of failure.
If either your database
or your web server goes down,
you're not able
to serve traffic.
So the next step,
which you'll probably run into
because you have exceeded
the amount of traffic
that one web app server--
or sorry--
one web server can handle
is that you'll take
your web server and split it
onto multiple machines.
This allows you
to serve more traffic
than one machine
is able to.
Obviously you have
to get a little more--
you have to get
some more machines.
But additionally, you have
to set up load balancing.
'Cause you have
to get the requests
to a different application
or different web servers.
One way to do this
that many people use
is what's called
DNS round robin.
What you do is you register
a list of IPs
with the domain name server,
so when your host name
is looked up,
one of the set
of IPs is returned.
And the domain name server
routes the request--
or tells the client
to route the request
to one of your front-ends.
This is a sort of statistical
load balancing.
It's not dependent
on the behavior application.
It's just spreading requests
evenly across them.
So one other thing that you do
when you set this up
is that when you register your
record with DNS,
you give it a time to live,
or a cache time.
This is great for DNS,
because it allows
them to hold on
to your configuration
for a while before having
to check to see if it's changed.
But the bad news is that
a lot of name servers
won't respect
your configuration.
And what this means
is if your--
whenever your web server
goes down,
now you have to wait for DNS
changes to propagate
and that may take a long time
to reach all the name servers.
So is it scalable?
Yeah, it's pretty good.
You can turn up as many
web servers as necessary
and as long as your
configuration isn't changing,
you're good to go.
But you're still I/O bound
on one database.
Additionally,
like I said before,
because of DNS round robin and
how long it takes
to update your configuration,
you can't redirect
your traffic quickly
and of course,
your database is still
a single point of failure.
The next step is to add what's
known as a reverse proxy.
What this will do
is it will take requests
from the network and then
do routing and load balancing
inside your network or inside
your application's stack.
This is a machine
that you control
that runs in your network.
It allows you
to do custom routing
and additionally it allows you
to do specialized back-ends,
because this reverse proxy
can be aware
of the configuration
that you're running
and can route different
requests to different back-ends.
So here, for example,
we see a request coming in,
hitting the reverse proxy,
and then based on whether
it's a request that
requires static content,
it's routed to the
static content server
there on the bottom
or it's routed
back to
the Apache web servers
for serving other kinds
of content.
This also allows you
to do
application-level
load balancing,
because your reverse proxy--
for example,
in the LiveJournal site
I showed earlier,
they were using Perlbal--
can be aware
of the load characteristics
of your web servers
and route--do sort of
a least-loaded
type load balancing policy
instead of round robin.
Requirements
for setting this up?
You're gonna need
more machines.
And you're gonna need
to do some configuration
and maybe write some
custom routing code
for your reverse proxy.
This works really well.
Perlbal and many other
reverse proxies are very robust.
They allow you
to do specialization,
which is great because
specialized back-ends
are generally more reliable
and since they have to do
a smaller breadth of work, they
do it a lot more effectively.
You're still bound
by the routing capacity
of one reverse proxy.
You can add more but then
you get into the same issues
we saw before
with DNS round robin
and not being able to change
your routing policy quickly.
You can get around that with
fancy network routing hardware
like a hardware load balancer.
But those things
are very expensive
and out of the reach
of most basic web developers.
Reliability-wise, you get agile
application-level routing.
You can move
application servers,
turn them up,
turn them down,
move your load around very,
very quickly,
because you control
the routing infrastructure.
You get to use
specialized components
like the static content server
we saw in the previous slide,
which allows you to have more
robust back-ends.
And again, we still
haven't addressed
the issue of the database,
which is still
a single point of failure.
So let's talk about that.
The next step, you would take
your one MySQL database
running on one machine
and spread it out
over two multiple machines
into what's known
as a master-slave
configuration.
This gets you better
read throughput
and it's invisible
to your application.
Rather, you don't have
to change
the way your
application functions
or accesses the database
in order to make use of this.
It's pretty much transparent.
Requirements, obviously,
you have to get more machines
and you have
to reconfigure MySQL.
But in general,
it's pretty straightforward.
Is it scalable?
Well, master-slave MySQL
or master-slave
for most databases,
a scale with a number of reads--
Sorry.
Scales the read rate
with the number of servers,
but not the right rate.
So here we can see--
Uh, oops.
This is...weird.
Okay, well,
I'm missing a slide.
But if, for example,
you had 400 reads per second--
400 writes per sec--
or, sorry.
If you had 200 writes per second
and 500 reads per second
on one machine
and you spread it over
to a master-slave MySQL,
your reads will be able
to hit any of the back-ends,
so you can spread them across
different machines,
but your writes
will hit the--
They all have to go
through the master
and then
be replicated through
to the other database servers.
So this is great, um...
for scaling up your reads,
but as your application
gets bigger and the net
throughput of writes
that you're doing also
increases proportionately,
you're going to soon exceed
the capacity
of one database server.
And at that point,
you're sort of out of luck
and you'll have to move
to a different configuration.
Regarding reliability,
the master is a single point
of failure for writes.
If it goes down,
you're no longer able
to write to your database.
And additionally, the master
may die before replication.
So as I said,
when you issue a write
to your database,
it hits the master server first
and then is replicated out
to the slaves.
If the master goes down
after writing
and before replication,
you may lose
a small window of data,
which is unfortunate.
The next step in scaling up
your database
is to use what's called
a partitioned database.
Effectively what this is
is you take your
master-slave MySQL database
or master-master
or any variety of configurations
and split it up
into different
database clusters.
This is done by a variety
of different
enterprise-level databases.
This is the way
that BigTable
and the App Engine
datastore work.
And additionally Oracle
clustered and db2 federated
work this way.
It gives you an increase
in both read
and write throughput,
which is great.
But the downside is that
it's a lot of work.
You need a lot more machines.
It requires a lot more
management, obviously.
But more importantly,
you're going to have
to re-architect your data model
to be partitioned.
The inherent assumptions
that you have
that all the data
is stored on one machine
or locally in one cluster
and you can do things
like joins
or in-memory operations,
that doesn't exist anymore.
So you may have
to rewrite your queries
in order to take advantage
of this.
So this brings us back
to the App Engine stack.
So again, we have the front-ends
on the left side.
They're basically App Engine's
reverse proxies.
They do application-level
routing and load balancing.
In the middle,
we have our app servers
and our static file
serving infrastructure,
which are responsible for
serving those respective parts
of an application.
And on the right side,
we have our datastore
built on BigTable,
memcache,
which is something many
of you may be familiar with.
And on the bottom we have
some other APIs
that your application
may make use of.
So now I want to talk about--
Given the progression of
infrastructure we saw before
to scale up a LAMP stack,
I want to talk about some
of the motivations
and design decisions that we
took into consideration
when designing App Engine.
The first was to build on
existing Google technology.
We didn't want to
re-invent any wheels
and Google spent
a lot of time building
and designing scalable
web infrastructure
and applications and we
wanted to use that experience
and use that infrastructure
and make it available
to all developers.
Additionally, we wanted
to provide
an integrated environment.
We wanted you
to be able to manage
the entirety of your
application in one place.
We wanted to encourage small
per-request footprints
and additionally,
fast requests,
so that we have high turnover
of requests
and not have to keep
too much stuff memory.
That allows us to do
the serving of applications
without using virtualization.
It's all on what's more similar
to a standard web server
than a giant,
clustered virtualization
or a pool of virtual instances.
We wanted to maintain isolation
between applications
and between applications
and Google.
So you can be assured that your
application is safe
from other applications,
both security-wise
and performance
characteristics.
If another application is
burning tons of CPU
or doing things like that,
it won't affect the way
that your application
performs.
We wanted to encourage you
to write applications
with statelessness and
specialization in mind.
Like I said before,
using specialized back-ends
gives you huge advantages
and having stateless requests
means that we can do
load balancing
and application routing
on a much more efficient scale.
Additionally,
you want to require
a partitioned data model.
I spoke before earlier about
how it's a very difficult step
to go from the sort of
regular database
or master-slave
or master-master MySQL
to a partitioned paradigm.
So we sort of make you write
for the App Engine datastore
from the beginning
and in that way,
you don't have
to re-architecture your data
when you get to that stage.
So now let's look
at the life of some requests
and see how they interact
with the different parts
of App Engine
and what goes on there.
So requests for static content.
The first thing that happens
in a request for static content
or any request
is that it's routed
to the nearest Google
datacenter
over the internet
and from there,
travels over Google's
network
to reach our
App Engine front-ends.
This is a huge advantage.
Basically, your application
is running
on the same network
and gets the same advantages
as all the other Google products
such as web search,
Gmail, and everything else.
You may notice decreased
latencies for this reason
and other
good characteristics.
Basically, you get lots
of advantages
just by being on this network.
The next thing that happens
once your request
reaches the
App Engine front-end,
is the front-end does
load balancing and routing.
In this case, since it's
a request for static content,
that request
will get routed
to the static content
back-ends.
And so this is a specialized
piece of infrastructure
that is wholly designed
to serve static content
and do it very effectively
and very efficiently.
And more importantly,
as you can see in this diagram,
your request has not touched
the App servers
or the other parts
of your application that can
be serving other
traffic independently.
So static content
servers built
on shared Google
infrastructure.
This is a entire service
inside Google,
of which App Engine
is not the only customer
and you can be assured
that it's very reliable,
very robust,
very large-scaled system.
This also means since
your request did not hit
your application servers
or any of the other
components that I talked
about earlier...
the files that are
on the static content serving
are actually physically
separate from the other files
that you deploy
with your application.
What this means and something
that some people observe
when using App Engine
is that when they deploy
their application
and then try to access files
which they've marked "static,"
they're unable to do so
on our App servers
because those files
are not actually
deployed to them.
So that begs the question,
"Which content is static?"
Well, you tell us
in your configuration
which you upload along
with your application.
For Java or
for the Java Runtime,
the appengine-web.xml file,
anything inside those static
XML tags is uploaded
to our static content servers.
And in App Engine--sorry.
In Python's app.yaml,
anything marked
"static directory"
or "static files"
matching those
regular expressions
will be served off
static content serving.
So afterwards,
the responses return
from the static content server
to the front-end
and then back out
to the user.
Again, we haven't touched any
of the other
infrastructure here,
which is really great
for scalability.
So the next request
I want to talk about
is a request
for dynamic content.
So to do that,
I need to talk about
a few different components that
I haven't brought up before.
One of which
is the App Engine App server
and the App Engine App master.
So the App server
is basically our web server.
It's job is to serve
dynamic requests.
When you do computation
or do API calls
or do anything
in your application
outside of the scope
of a static request,
it ends up at the App server
and the App server
is responsible
for managing those requests.
The App master
is another piece
which is a little bit different
from what we saw before
in the standard scaled-up
version of the LAMP stack.
Its job is to manage and
schedule applications
on App servers.
Additionally, it informs
the front-ends of where those--
what applications
are scheduled
on which app server
so they can be routed.
So requests can be routed.
So a little more detail
on the app server.
App servers serve
many applications--
many, many applications--
and they also serve
many concurrent requests.
So harking back
to what I said about
some of our
design motivations,
smaller app footprints
in terms of memory and CPU,
plus faster requests,
allows us to serve
more applications
more effectively
and make better use
of resources.
The app server
is also responsible
for enforcing isolation
between applications
and between applications
and Google.
This keeps apps safe
from each other
and additionally,
it keeps us safe from apps.
So it also enforces
statelessness,
which is really important
because since we don't know
what your application
is doing or what state
it needs to maintain,
if an app server goes down
or if there's some
other issue and we need
to reroute requests
for traffic,
we don't have
to transfer any state.
You use your APIs
to maintain state
and they're stored
on a different
piece of
infrastructure entirely
so applications
can be rescheduled
or traffic can be rerouted
across app servers
without having to worry
about moving state around.
And then of course,
the app servers
also service API requests
for your application.
So the first step in routing
a dynamic content request
is at the front-end.
Any requests that don't match
static requests
and match one of the other
regular expressions
in your configuration,
get routed to the app servers.
The app server checks to see if
there's a runtime in the cache
and I'll talk about it
a little more in a second.
If that exists, it uses it.
Otherwise, it turns up on your
runtime for your application.
Executes the request
and then holds on
to that runtime in memory.
This is a really important
part of App Engine,
because it means two things.
First of all, your first request
to an App Engine app server
may be slow.
We may have to do
a little more overhead
to get your application
up and running the first time.
But then subsequent requests are
likely to hit that cache.
The front-ends are designed
to maximize
this sort of caching.
But the second and more
important benefit for you all
is that because this request--
because the runtime
hangs around in memory,
you're able to use
that memory across requests.
There are no guarantees
it will still be there.
The cache may be evicted
at any time.
But you can optimistically
cache either
things that are
expensive to initialize
or compute or import
or anything like that
in your runtime
and it may be there
when your next request comes in,
which is really nice.
So the next type of request
is a request accessing an API.
This is inside the scope
of a dynamic request,
but if your request decides
to make an API call,
it requests permission
from the app server
and then the app server
will block the runtime
of your request,
issue the API call,
and then wake up the runtime
again with the response.
This is really cool because
it means you don't
have to manage concurrency
and threading on your own.
It's managed in
the app server for your app.
And because your application
is stateless,
we don't have worry
too much about
what your application needs
when it wakes up.
We just hand back the response
and you're good to go.
You're, uh--
You can use APIs
to do things
that you wouldn't normally
want to either do
in the app server because
you have limited resources
or because you don't want
to rewrite them for yourself.
We have a lot of APIs that do
a lot of specialized tasks
and now I want
to go through and--
Well, here's a few of them.
So memcache and the datastore we
have talked about a lot.
URLfetch is our API for fetching
our content from the web.
There's the mail API.
And then two new ones
that we haven't
really talked about before are
the XMPP API,
which is on our road map.
Kevin talked
about it this morning.
And then the task queue API,
which is for
offline computation,
which is something we're
really excited about
and there's a talk later
in the conference
about a look ahead
at offline processing
for App Engine, which
I encourage you all to go to.
Additionally,
we have images and users.
So first API I want
to talk about is memcache
or our flavor of memcache,
memcacheg.
So memcache is a distributed
in-memory cache
that's used across
the industry fairly heavily.
Many of you work
with LAMP stacks
and things like that
may be familiar with it.
The more common variant
of memcache
is called memcached
and it was written
for LiveJournal by Brad
and the folks there
to get better performance out
of their in-memory cache.
So memcacheg,
which is the version we use,
was also written
by Brad and adds a couple
of extra API calls that you may
not find in memcached,
which are batch API calls,
such as
set_multi, get_multi,
and add_multi,
which allow you
to incur the overhead
of doing RPC less often.
Basically, you can use memcache
to optimistically cache
data in-memory on a set
of sharded servers
for optimization.
Things you might want
to cache in memcache are
the results
of database queries,
of an expensive call
to fetch something
from the internet,
or something that just requires
a lot of computation
on your application.
You may want to hold
on to it
and not have to do it
on every request.
Memcache is a very
specialized back-end.
It's just an in-memory cache.
And that means
that it can be---
It's very stable
and very robust.
Things in memcache
may hang around longer
than you would
necessarily expect.
BigTable is the next--
Or rather the App Engine
datastore which is built
on BigTable is the next API
I want to talk about.
And it's our API for doing
persistent storage.
Like I said,
we don't want you to--
We want to maintain
stateless requests
and stateless applications
at the app server,
so you need somewhere to put
your persistent state
where you'll be sure
it'll be there
when your next request
comes in.
And for us, that's
the App Engine datastore.
I spoke a little bit before
about partitioned datastores
and the advantages
that those give you
with regard to read
and write throughput.
We don't want to make
you jump through the hoops
of partitioning your data
once your application
gets to a certain scale.
So--and because we wanted
to use BigTable,
we make you design
for this type
of database
from the beginning.
You can use entity groups
in your application
to control your partitions.
You may also have to define
explicit indexes
for your datastore entities
so that reads are instantaneous.
We don't want to do a lot
of computation on reads,
so everything has to be a quick
read from the database
with no complicated
in-memory calculation.
Additionally, we have
to update those indexes
when a request--
when a write comes through.
So you might see that writes
will be a bit slower.
Because we're built
on BigTable,
you get a high degree
of replication
and fault tolerance.
As soon as your--
As soon as your mutation
on your datastore--
your datastore
mutation commits,
you're guaranteed by the time
that API call returns
your data's been replicated
to at least three machines.
And this is without you having
to do any extra work.
The reason for this is that the
datastore is built on BigTable
and BigTable's built on GFS.
Both BigTable and GFS
have white papers
on research.google.com,
which you are more
than welcome to check out,
which explain exactly
the mechanics
of how all of this work.
But that's a topic itself.
And then the other bonus
you get from using the datastore
is that you get to keep
globally unique I.D.s
across partitions.
Each of your entities
is uniquely identified.
And you don't have to do any
work to set this up.
This is something
that you could do
with a regular
partition database,
but it requires some more work
to set up the servers
and to set up a back-end
to assign these unique I.D.s,
which is already
built in for you
with the App Engine datastore.
Some other APIs
that I want to talk about
are the mail API,
which uses the same
routing infrastructure
as Gmail,
the user's API,
which gives you seamless
accounts integration.
Images API,
which does image manipulation
and resizing,
is used by Picasaweb
to do some of their image
manipulation and resizing.
URLfetch, which fetches
content from the web,
it's used by the Gadget API.
And then the task queue
and XMPP.
XMPP is gonna use the same XMPP
server as Google Talk.
So the really,
really important thing to--
The really important takeaway
from all of this
is that the majority of these
APIs are backed by servers.
They're used across Google
by products
much, much bigger
than App Engine.
So there are entire teams
devoted to maintaining
and supporting and upgrading
these services.
And you get all
these advantages
just by using App Engine
and making simple API calls.
You don't have to go through
the overhead
of writing the code
or figuring out
the corner cases
and things like that
for your application.
So with that,
I want to talk about--
I want to go back
to the design motivations
I spoke about before and discuss
in a little more detail,
now that we've taken a look
at the infrastructure,
how your application
is affected by them,
why we made
those decisions,
and what it means for you
as an app developer.
So our first design motivation
was to build
on existing Google technology.
Google spends--
Google spent years
and lots of time
and lots of money working
on our infrastructure,
building our data centers,
and also learning
how to make web apps scale
and infrastructure reliable.
We wanted to make use of all
of this in our APIs
and with App Engine
serving stack in general
to give you all
those benefits.
You don't have to know what's
happening behind the scenes
with regards to all
of the scaling.
It just works.
And so, related to that,
we wanted to provide
an integrated environment so
that it would truly
be simple to develop
on App Engine.
For us, our motivation
was based on
managing all
applications together.
We wanted to provide
one service
and let you control
how your application is--
Or give you a platform
by which you can control
how you application is served
and how your application runs.
What it means for you
is that you may
have to follow some
of our best practices.
Because you're working
in an integrated environment,
things may be different
than what you may expect
on one box running
a LAMP stack.
You may encounter
some restrictions
because
of the specialization
and isolation that
I talked about earlier.
Our tools?
You may have to use interact
with our system.
However, we try to make them
as open as possible.
But additionally, we think
that they're pretty great.
For example,
our development environment,
as mentioned in the keynote,
is a three-megabyte download
that allows you to mimic the
App Engine serving environment
on your local machine
to allow you to do development
locally and then integrate
very quickly
in developing applications.
Once your application
is deployed,
you can use our admin console
at appengine.google.com
to manage your application
from one place.
You get ben--
Because of that,
you get benefits such as having
your logs integrated
and in one place.
I don't know how many
of you ever tried
to correlate your
web server logs
with your application
server logs
and figure out which
application logs correspond
to which web requests.
But it's not always
so straightforward.
With the admin console,
that's all done for you
and it's there online and
searchable all the time.
Additionally,
you don't have to manage
or configure any machines.
You don't know how many
app servers
your application's running on.
That's all managed
transparently for you.
And all of these
give you the benefit
of ease of deployment
and fast iterative development,
which allows you
to be a more efficient
and effective
software developer.
So the second motivation was
to encourage
per-request footprints.
Like I said, many
applications and my requests
concurrently run
on the same infrastructure,
the same app servers
and we wanted to make
good use of our app servers
and make sure
that applications are fair
in that the way--
we're fair in the way
that we distribute resources
across these applications.
What it means
for your application?
Well, you may get
less memory usage than
you're used to running
on a machine that you control.
And additionally, less CPU.
However, we think that this
is a good thing in many ways,
because it encourages you make
better use of resources
and allows you to use
our APIs to do some of the more
intensive tasks
and not have to do them
on your own machine.
We want to encourage
fast requests
to make better use
of our app servers.
Again, better fairness--
or more fairness
between applications.
Sort of very similar
to the last slide.
But a fast request also
give us the added benefit
of being able to do agile
routing and scheduling.
If a request is quick
and they're--
for an application,
we're able to move
that application
or redistribute
the load very quickly.
We don't have to wait for your
requests that are in-flight
to complete before
we can move it.
It also means,
like I said before,
because applications
are run quickly
and are able to share
the same runtimes,
you get to make use of better
runtime caching
and you may run into things that
just request deadlines.
Benefits to your application?
Well, because
of runtime caching,
you're able
to optimistically share state
between your requests.
You're gonna see more throughput
or better throughput
and better performance
in general
if your requests are fast.
For the same number
of live serving runtimes,
you're able to serve
a lot more traffic
if your requests are faster.
You also get better
fault tolerance.
If you have less
requests in-flight
at any given moment and there
is some kind of failure,
less of your requests
will be canceled because of it.
Also, additionally,
better use of resources.
The less you consume
of your App Engine resources,
the less--
the more you have
to use later of our free quotas
and additionally paid quotas.
The next thing we wanted
to do was maintain
isolation between applications.
So this is for
two main reasons.
Safety.
We want applications
to not have to worry
about the other
applications running
additionally
on our infrastructure.
And predictability.
We don't want one application's
performance
to impact another application's
performance.
This means your
application may see
that certain system calls
are unavailable.
You don't have
raw network access.
You may not get some
of the extensions.
The C extensions on Python
that you're used to using.
The benefits are
you can be assured
that your application
is secure in the sense
that no applications
can touch it.
Additionally, no one can SSH
into your machine.
You're not running on a machine
that's out there in the wild.
You're running behind
a lot of other stuff
that gives you a--
that can give you
a sense of security.
Additionally, you're gonna
get better performance
because you're not running
on the same--
you're not affected
by other applications'
serving characteristics.
So I also want to talk
about statelessness
and specialization.
This is something that
I mentioned a couple of times.
And it's really
important for us
in order to be able to serve
so many applications
in this manner.
For us, it allows us to have
better app server performance,
because we don't have to manage
and maintain state.
It allows us to do better
load balancing
for the reasons
I mentioned earlier.
Our App Engine front-ends
can move applications
across web servers
very quickly
and manage your
load dynamically,
because they don't have
to move any state around.
And additionally,
because you don't have
any state to maintain,
you don't have
any state to lose,
so your application
will be very fault tolerant,
because the APIs are what are--
The systems behind the APIs
are what are
holding on to that state.
And then this means your
application
should use API calls
to do things that are
provided for you.
This is really great because
you get the advantage
of automatic load
balancing because
of the better scheduling that we
can do and fault tolerance.
And additionally,
it's less code for you to write.
If you want
to manipulate images
or if you want to send mail
or have a user accounts,
you don't have to write
all that code yourself.
You can use our back-ends
that are specialized,
dedicated systems that are
only--
Their only job is to do these
types of jobs for you.
And then finally,
we wanted to require
a partitioned data model.
The main reason for
this is that we wanted
to be able to give you BigTable
and the datastore.
We want people to learn
that it's not so hard
to write applications
with this data model
and you get a lot
of advantages.
What it means
for your application
is that it may have to--
You may have to design
your data model differently
than you would
if you were using
a MySQL database running
on one machine.
You will have to define indexes
for all queries.
But you'll see
that your writes
are very, very fast.
Your--I'm sorry.
Your reads are very,
very fast.
Your writes may be
a bit slower,
but you don't have
to go through the pain
of designing your schema
or redesigning your schema
or re-architecting
your application.
And the hardest time
for an application
is when your application load
starts to grow.
You've already done it,
so you're already ready.
Additionally,
you get more efficient use
of CPU memory because you
pre-compute things
at write time and then when you
read them it's very fast
and in-memory.
This--
So this sort of shapes--
This sort of elucidates
the kind of applications
that are great
for running an App Engine,
applications
that are read intensive.
Most web applications
fit this mold,
so we think
it's a really good fit.
So now I want to talk
a little bit about
App Engine numbers
and talk about some data
that we haven't
shared previously.
So some of this was...
set up
at keynote this morning,
but currently on App Engine,
we have over
80,000 applications.
And those applications
are serving
over 140 million
page views per day,
which is a lot
of traffic.
And then we have
over 200,000 developers,
which is something we're really
excited about.
We're really excited
that so many people
have given App Engine a try and
found that it works for them
and have all these
applications running.
And then to dig
in a little bit deeper
and talk about one application
that was also
mentioned a bit earlier,
the White House
had an "open for questions"
application.
Sort of a case study
in how well applications
can scale in App Engine.
Basically, what
"open for questions" was
was it's an instance
of Google Moderator
that was running on
the White House's website.
And what they did was they
solicited questions
from everyday Americans
and votes on those questions
to sort of crowd source
the best questions
about different
policy issues
that were affecting
the Obama administration
and in the course
of over 48 hours,
the application
accepted 100,000 questions
and 3.6 million votes,
which is huge in just 48 hours.
The application went
from serving zero traffic
to having 3.6 million votes
and 100,000 applications
in just under 48 hours.
And then at the end
of all of this,
President Obama,
in a live televised
press conference, answered
the highest-rated questions
from some of those topics.
This was really exciting
for us
and really exciting
as App Engine developers
and as Americans in general
to get that kind
of interactivity between us
and our government.
So you can take
a look at the graph.
You'll see that White House
kickoff blog posts--
WhiteHouse.gov got
a little bit of traffic.
A little bit.
100 QPS of traffic
is actually
kind of a lot of traffic.
And then in the afternoon,
we got a mention on NPR,
New York Times coverage,
and CNN coverage.
And then at 5:00,
there was a link
on the Google homepage
for the White House application.
And then before submission,
this application
peaked at a load of about 700
queries per second,
which is a very,
very high amount of load.
And then they cut off voting
and the traffic
came down really quickly.
And so with that,
I'll open it up to questions.
I'll pull up
the Moderator page
and if you want
to ask live questions,
you can walk up
to the microphones as well.
Thank you.
[applause]
That's weird.
All right.
man: I'm curious what you
were just saying
about Google Moderator.
If you guys developed
that in-house
and deployed it on behalf
of whitehouse.gov
or if it's
an open source project
that you had previously built
that their developers
deployed without
any sort of changes
that you would have
had to make
to scale
to that size?
Levi: So Moderator
is an open source project
that is available
for anyone to deploy.
The White House made
a few changes
for a variety
of different reasons.
Privacy and
increasing performance.
They wanted to really get that
tuned as best as possible.
But they deployed
the application
and it's there for anybody
to download
and deploy their own.
man: Did that take much work
from you guys
for them to be able to get it
to scale to that level?
Levi: We were there
to support them.
But, um, yeah.
I mean, it was really
important for us
and we kept a close eye
on it to make sure
that it went well,
but, yeah,
it was a really
big success.
And additionally,
it didn't impact
any other
applications serving
on App Engine,
which is huge.
man: Hi.
Levi: Yes.
man: You talked about some
of these Google applications
that we can use as part
of the App Engine.
You know, like, mail and chat
and those kinds of things.
Is there a plan
to give something
like a search itself
as an application?
Levi: Search itself as an API?
man: As an API.
Levi: So we would very much
like to have
full text search
in our datastore.
Because we sort of are
rethinking the way
that we do certain things
in order to make it available
to lots of applications.
And on a request-based model,
we've had to sort of
redesign some of the things
that you sort of take
for granted that Google's good
at, like search.
All I can say is that we're
working on it
and we'd very much
like to have
a search in our datastore.
man: Right, thank you.
Levi: Yeah, you're welcome.
And then I'll take some
of these questions here.
I'll take one question
up here first.
This looks like--
yes.
"Is there a way to pre-load
big libraries
"such as Django 1.x rather
than delaying requests
for several seconds while
zipserve loads it?"
So like I said,
you can take those libraries
and use your runtime caching.
If you use a main method
in your Python,
we will cache everything
in your global space
for the next request
on the same app server.
So while I don't
know if there's a way
to pre-load big libraries
so that your first request
has them already in there.
Already, like,
hot and on the app server.
Subsequent requests should see
an increase to performance.
man: So it seems like
from this morning's demo,
you're making a big effort
to integrate GWT,
particularly the Eclipse plug-in
and all that stuff
with App Engine,
which is awesome.
But it makes me wonder whether
that's not gonna
leave the Python runtime
behind.
Is there any plans
on the road map
to do the same kind of one-click
magic stuff in Eclipse
that we saw this morning?
Levi: That's a really good
question.
I don't know exactly
what is in the plan.
I'm sure we'd like
to do things like that.
But there's nothing
on the road map at this time.
I'll take another one
from here.
"In order to take advantage
of application caching,
"should you avoid inline
"imports" in your Python code?
How do you ensure your code
is cached optimally?"
That's a really good question.
So it's sort of
a trade-off, right?
If you put all your imports
at the top of your Python code,
all of your imports
are gonna get imported
on your first request
and they're gonna hang around
on the app server cache
for your runtime
and be available
to the next request.
However, that's gonna make your
first request much slower.
If you break up
your imports into only
the code paths
that need them,
you'll be doing less
than a per-request basis.
So that's more of, like--
more of something you need
to figure out for application,
and see what works best.
man: So you've done
some work to avoid
hitting the App Engine
all the time
so, like, serving static files
or doing the image access.
There's pricing for, like, Gmail
sending mail
through that API,
but how do you price
serving static pages?
Is that just free or does
that count as compute cycles?
Or how do you kind of calculate
all the API usage
and static usage?
Levi: So we still charge
for bandwidth
in most cases, but you
don't consume any CPU cycles,
which is the most expensive
resource that there is
that we have, yeah.
man: Could you talk a bit
about data portability
and moving data in and out
of the BigTable datastore?
Levi: Sure.
I can mention it briefly.
We have some libraries,
our bulk uploader
and bulk downloader
that will get data in and out
in a common format.
I don't know.
And those are available
on the website
for you to use to get your
data in and out, yeah.
Is there anything
more specific or?
man: Not in particular,
but if you have
maybe an example of a company
that has, like,
multiple systems maybe partially
built on App Engine
and then they have maybe
something on Amazon systems.
Do you have experience
with that?
Levi: Hmm.
Mike?
Do we know
of any such companies
that have data on App Engine
and port their data
between EC2 and App Engine?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Levi: Yeah, so then it's on.
Levi: "App Engine Nitty Gritty"
is the talk
that's gonna be
on later today.
Yeah, welcome.
Take one more from Moderator.
"I see datastore timeouts
seemingly without
"any difference in my deployed
code or usage patterns.
"Is there a way
to get more information
about why the datastore
is timing out?"
So you can take a look
a little bit--
Your logs will give you
some indication
of when your datastore
is timing out
and some
of the reasons based on--
If there's contention,
that'll show up in the logs.
And there may be some
other reasons.
I encourage you to go
to Ryan Barrett's talk
on the App Engine datastore
and ask him
these types of questions,
'cause he's
really the expert on it.
Uh, please.
man: Hi.
Ert Dredge from
Universal Metaphor.
Can you outline if there's
any significant differences
between the Python and Java
flavors that you have,
either right now or
in the road maps,
or are they--
as far as the restrictions
you get for App Engine,
are they pretty close
to the same capabilities?
Levi: Well, we want to try
to keep both of them
in line as far as their
capabilities
and we continue to update
and maintain
API-level equivalence
between the two.
I don't know specifically.
Is there anything specific
that you were--
man: I'm right now agnostic
and actually looking
and choosing one
versus the other.
And I was wondering
if there was,
well, yes, we plan on having
this capability
on one side,
or Java hasn't yet caught up
to that capability?
If there's any major
differences you know of.
Levi: I think that we're
committed to maintaining
the same capabilities across
both runtimes, yeah.
man: Thanks.
Levi: Yes?
man: This is another
zip import
kind of app
or module caching question.
But you mentioned that
the App Engine will cache
the module for that application
on the same app server.
And many people
have kind of found out
that those modules are cached
for a number of seconds,
but after a few seconds
of not having a request,
that module will get
kind of dropped.
And so also, if, like,
the application--or if
it's cached for that
app server and you have
multiple app servers in the
App Engine infrastructure...
Levi: Sure.
man: how many requests
per second, basically,
would you need to have before,
like, you would,
basically not have to input
the modules every single time,
or not expect to, like, have
users getting slow requests?
Levi: Um, right.
That's a good question.
So, basically,
what kind of sustained
requests-per-second
would you need
to keep your runtime
in the cache?
I don't know what--
I don't know if there's really
a specific answer to that,
because it sort
of changes dynamically,
both with the amount
of traffic
that we're seeing across all
of App Engine,
because caches
will get cycled out
as more requests
come in
and they're handled
sort of in a first--
They're handled--
We handle them equivalently,
so I don't know
if there is
a specific answer
in terms of, like, a number
I can give you regarding that.
man: Okay.
Levi: Excuse me?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Um.
Yeah, I really don't know.
It sort of depends
on your application load too,
'cause once you start
seeing more traffic,
you may get scheduled
on more app servers,
which means that you'll
have more caches
to maintain hot and it's--
Yeah, I really don't--
I really can't answer
that question.
We'll take one
from Moderator again.
"With the App Engine datastore,
can I control
"where my data is replicated
in BigTable?
"For example,
if I don't want my data
"to be replicated outside
of the U.S.
"or, conversely,
into the U.S.,
can I 'pin' the data
to a specific geolocation?"
So in general regarding
data replication,
your data is replicated
and currently
I don't think--
We would like
to give developers control
over where their data is
or where their application
serves from and we're
working on that,
but we don't have that
capability right now.
[man speaking indistinctly]
In--so--
So E requires data
to stay within you.
I'm sure that we abide
by the various laws.
[laughter]
But I don't know the specifics
regarding that though.
Um, so--
So yeah.
Let's take another question.
man: Michael [indistinct]
of Dynamics Software.
You addressed a great deal
of scalability shifts.
Thank you.
What about complexity
of the application?
How complex the app would be?
That's question number one.
Question number two:
What about background
housekeeping kind of thing?
Is it possible at all?
Because the more complex
the application,
you definitely need it.
Levi: Great.
Both great questions.
So in terms of complexity,
because you're using APIs,
which take some
of the complexity out
of the scope of your application
and push it back
to dedicated services.
Your application or the code
that you deploy
can be much less complex,
because you don't
have to do that work yourself.
And then secondly, in terms
of background processing
or offline processing,
we have it on our roadmap
and we're giving a talk.
I think it's tomorrow
is Brett's talk
on offline processing,
a look ahead.
And he'll give you
a look into the different
kinds of things
you can do offline.
Actually, although right now
we do have Kron support.
So you can use that
to do that sort of outside
of the scope
of the requests processing.
man: David Ellsworth,
Ogopogo web pages.
Do you have equipment
operating in China?
Levi: Um, I don't--
In general, we don't discuss
the location
or any details regarding
the data centers.
So I'm not gonna be able
to answer that.
man: When I want
to implement App Engine
for an enterprise
and it has a brand,
if I want to disable the apps
portal, is it possible?
You know, to hide the
implementation of, like--
Let's say I created
an application
called
brandstore@mydomainname.com,
and I don't want
that brand located,
or whatever the name
which I use as an app I.D.,
that I can access
basically using
application I.D.
dot app support dot com.
Which, if I want to hide it--
Levi: So do you want
to hide that that exists
or do you want to hide the
content that's on the site?
man: I want to hide
the app support URL
and just--I want to just use
mybrandname--
mydomainname.com/someapplication
name.
Levi: I see.
I don't know exactly
what you can do for that.
If you're concerned about
revealing your web site
before it's ready,
you can deploy
a second major version
and then have
the default version display some
sort of static content
or some sort of placeholder
until you're ready
to switch it over.
But I don't know offhand
how you would go about disabling
App Spot.
Yes?
[man speaking indistinctly]
man: For example, like,
I have an application
that says, like,
let's say
applicationname.mydomain.com.
So when I create
that application I.D.,
you and I can access
the same application
using applicationid.appspot.com.
[man speaking indistinctly]
man: Okay, yeah.
Think so.
Levi: Yeah.
Then I'll take one more
over here.
Well, I'll take two,
'cause pretty straightforward.
The first is are we planning
to provide a way
for deleting an application?
We would very much like
to provide a way
to delete an application,
but it's on a long list
of other things
we'd like to do
and it's just not the top
of the priorities right now.
So, yeah.
At present, no, you can't delete
an application,
but it's definitely something
we'd like to provide.
And will this presentation
be available online?
Yes, it will be.
I think it'll be on YouTube,
but I don't
know specifics
on all this stuff.
I'm sure it'll be
in the conference material.
man: Are there any plans
for being able
to establish
a trust relationship
between a couple datastores
so you can make requests
across those or is it
always going forward,
gonna be distinct, you can't
from a security perspective?
Levi: That's definitely
something we've talked about
and I think it's something
that is really valuable.
I don't think that we have any
plans to do that now,
but we're definitely
thinking about it.
And again, if you want
to talk to Ryan after,
he may be able to give you
more insight into that stuff.
man: Hi, my name
is Scott Lahey.
Thanks for taking
my question.
My question is around
the economics of App Engine.
As an example,
how much would it have cost
to run that White House
application for a developer
and is there, like,
a cutoff point
where, you know,
that Google's thinking about
or that is kind
of the de facto where you say,
"Hey, once you, you know,
kind of hit this level,
"economically it makes
more sense to sort of move
off the platform on
to your own thing"?
Levi: Right.
So I don't know specifics
about how much
it would have cost
or how much
it would cost to run the open
for questions White House app.
In general, I think we have
about 5 million page views
is what we shoot for--
obviously it depends
on how you write
your application--
for the free quota,
which is absolutely free.
And then--
[man speaking indistinctly]
Oh, sorry.
5 million page views
per month?
Is that right?
Yeah.
5 million pages per month.
And then, secondly, to the
second part of your question,
which was regarding how high an
application can get--
So there are some limits
in place that are safety limits
that an application--
So that the peak of an
application can serve right now.
But if you want to exceed
past those limits,
feel free to contact someone
on the App Engine team
and we can definitely
talk about those.
Those are just in place sort
of as a safety measure
and can be removed
on a case-by-case basis.
man: Thank you.
man: I'm curious.
I know that when you had
problems serving
a couple of months ago,
they were saying
that applications
with a certain profile,
if they're more dynamic
or static,
would hit limitations when
others would serve just fine.
Are there certain best practices
that you should maintain
in the event of an outage
or something
where you could have
static fallback content
or something like that?
Levi: Sure, yeah, definitely.
Static fallback content
is great.
We have certain APIs may throw
capability exceptions,
which you can catch
and then handle.
So, for example,
if during certain periods,
we may go into read-only mode
for the datastore
or your memcache may
be unavailable for some reason
or something like that,
but those APIs
will throw specific exceptions
for those cases
which you can then catch and
then handle appropriately.
man: What about something
like letting Python
manage your URLs?
If the Python app server
goes down,
then your entire app
goes down.
Or if that were an app.yaml,
I don't know
if that would reroute
to static or if there's--
Levi: So the app server going
down entirely
isn't really something
that we are--
So that's not really,
like, the big concern.
It's more--
I think the cases
that you're talking about
were very specific
to maybe a set of APIs back-ends
that were available.
And so just using those
in a robust way
and following some
of the best practices
that I think--
For in terms
of scalability also,
which I think are
gonna be covered in a talk later
about best practices
for building scaled apps.
man: Cool. Thank you.
Levi: Um, so...
"I've seen a Google application
run very--
"a Google App Engine app
run very slowly.
"This is an application
that worked quickly
"and has very few users.
"Can you describe
what causes this
"and what we can do?
"Is it because
of a big bandwidth user
such as whitehouse.gov?"
So, first off, it's not because
of a big bandwidth user
such as whitehouse.gov.
Because of the isolation
that I talked about before,
applications don't really
affect the way
that the other ones serve.
So specifically,
it's very difficult to say
from this much information.
It could be a variety
of different reasons
why your application
may run slowly
even though are
a few number of users.
If you follow
our best practices,
hopefully you can get
around that.
And there's at least
one talk today--
Today or tomorrow,
I'm not sure--
about how to
do that effectively.
Yeah?
man: Yeah, I was interested
in if there was any plans
for parallel URL fetch.
Basically if being able
to request--
If you only have 30 seconds
to run
and you spend half
of that blocking--
If there are any plans?
Levi: So that's
definitely something
we are--
Are we?
Yeah, that's definitely
something that we want to do.
I think that it's available.
Is it?
I don't really know.
Soon.
Yes, soon.
If not now.
[laughter]
man: Yeah, one thing that we've
observed occasionally
is the very front-end
of the App Engine
kind of goes haywire
and you get, you know, errors
that basically don't
then occur in the--
You don't see in the App Engine
logs, basically,
because it's at that
first level of the tier
that's erroring out.
Is there any plans
or thoughts about--
And I don't think
that those generate
the same kind of, like,
alerts that you might get.
Levi: Right.
So...that definitely does happen
from time to time
and there are a variety
of reasons why that may happen
and there are factors
that contribute to it
based on whether you're
serving off of App Spot
or you're serving off
of a custom domain,
because those different requests
will take different paths
getting to App Engine.
And so I can't speak
to specific cases.
But there are some factors,
some of which
are in our control
and some which are not,
since we're customers
of a lot of services
inside Google also.
Let's see.
Um...
So I'll answer one more from
here and then--
Uh, and then--
Wait, which one?
"New applications
with a low number of requests
"really suffer from a lack
of application caching.
"Do you have suggestions
to improve app spin-up time
"and/or can app caching
be adjusted
for these low traffic apps?"
So for those
low traffic apps,
one of the things
you can do is not
do all of your importing
and initialization
at the top of your function
or at the top
of your request script
and do it only
for those paths which
the request will follow.
So doing in-line imports
and things like that may help.
[man speaking indistinctly]
So I don't know what the best
practices are for Java.
I think there's a talk
that's Java-specific
going on for App Engine
a little bit later today.
man: I think it's
the next talk.
Levi: Oh, great.
Next talk, that would
be the right place
to ask that question
for Java.
man: When you
were mentioning
that hot apps keep
the memory around,
specifically, how do you
take advantage of that?
I would assume memcache
is one way.
Imports are probably hot.
But does that
actually apply
to variables within
Python instances?
It does?
Levi: Yeah.
man: So that seems like
it changes
the programming model
a little bit.
How would you best take
advantage of those
instance data that
is actually around for you?
Levi: So for Python
specifically or--
Matthew's got--
[man speaking indistinctly]
Yeah, so we can talk more
about that specifically.
Oh, we're gonna be holding
office hours across the way
and you can come to us
with specific questions.
But I've got to wrap
it up anyway,
so thank you all
for coming.
[applause]